d'après vous je suis normal ou pas
normal normal mademoiselle d'après vous
normal ou pas normal norm comment norm
normal bah oui moi aussi je me trouve et
ben pas pour tout le monde pour Hitler
j'étais pas normal parce que j'étais
juive pendant de nombreuses heures les
près de 600 élèves du lycée Notre-Dame
des Z de Blois ont bu les paroles de
Ginette colinka de son séjour à Drancy
puis à Birkenau et Bergen bsen n'élude
aucun détail de la barbarie des nazis la
violence physique comme la violence
morale dès l'arrivée dans le camp de
concentration que des humiliation la
nudité le tatouage alors maintenant ça y
est on est
tatoué et on va nous
emmener se faire raser alors on vous
enlève les poils du sexe on vous enlève
les cheveux on est transformé en des
êtres inhumains tout de suite a presè ce
que 99 ans Ginette Kanka n'a qu'un
objectif transmettre sa mémoire et ses
souvenirs au plus grand nombre pour
qu'une fois les derniers témoins disparu
les générations futures puissent se
souvenir et raconter vous aissz quelque
chose et ben rappelez-vous que c'est un
pied dans awit les négationnistes on
peut leur dire tout ce qu'on veut s'ils
sont décidés de dire que ça n'a pas
exister vous inquiétez pas ils vont
revenir à l'attaque dès qu'il y aura
plus personne pour parler un témoignage
lourd parfois difficile à entendre et
qui marquera sans doute longtemps les
jeunes auditeurs du jour c'est
intéressant de d'avoir les détails des
habitations au niveau de de comment
était organisé le camp des voyages en
train aussi de comment ça se passer les
tatouages je m'imaginais pas trop ça
c'est quand même exceptionnel qu'on ait
eu la chance de pouvoir la rencontrer
pouvoir l'entendre que bah même si on
peut pas vraiment savoir ce qu'elle a
vécu on peut
le connaître un peu et oui je trouve ça
incroyable qu'on ait pu entendre cela
c'est toujours difficile d'entendre des
personnes parler de ce qu'ils ont vécu
mais je pense que c'est intéressant de
savoir et d'entendre de viv
voix ces atrocités c'est très chargé en
émotion en dehors de ses rencontres avec
les élèves l'histoire de Ginette Kanka a
été éditée sous forme de bande dessiné
et autres ouvrages pour que son plus
grand rêve supprimer le mot haine ne se
réalise pour t
J